I'm being 9 30 I would like to call this
meeting of long-range Capital planning
and utilization committee to order
um
there is a quorum present
and the first item of business is the
acceptance of the minutes of the May
23rd and July 13th meetings is our
motion to do that
representative McConkey seconded by
Senator birdsil to accept the minutes of
May 23rd and July 13th all those in
favor signify by saying aye
opposed nay the eyes have it and the
minutes are approved
there is no old business first item of
new business RSA fourth colon 39-b
approval estate agency leases exceeding
five years
lrcp
22-027 Department of Natural and
cultural resources requests approval to
enter into a 10-year lease agreement in
the amount of three million 830
371.68 payable and equal monthly
installments with McCarthy properties of
West where where Massachusetts for 25
200 square feet of total office space
for the Department's use located at 172
Pembroke Road in Concord New Hampshire
effective from October 1st 2022 through
December 30th 2032 subject to the
conditions as specified in the request
dated September 1st 2022 is there
anybody from the Department here
actually there wasn't consumer of
September 30th yeah okay
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Chris Marino I'm
the chief of administration for the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources
uh thank you so before you today is a
request for a lease for building for a
building for 10 years at our current
location
this uh this lease um we're seeking for
10 years based on a couple of factors
one being cost savings as proposed by
the landlord
um
at the best rate which at this current
rate based on the proposal that was
provided uh 13.25 cents a square foot
Which is far below market value within
the Concord area
we've been at this building for
approximately 30 years
um in the last few years we have
on a couple of occasions sought an RFP
for additional space as you might recall
we were dread the department of resource
and economic development in 2017 that
changed
we did seek an RFP for lease base at the
time that nothing materialized that even
came close so we sought an extension
then we went out one more time two years
later again we delayed sought an
extension
uh I'm sorry we had a one year request
and then a two-year uh seeking an
extension uh this time around we have
decided to pursue a lease to stay for a
period of time
um with under the guidance of
administrative Services we did receive a
waiver from the RFP process due to the
circumstances and the information
relative to costs in particular that is
13.25 cents a square foot is far below a
cost for any
similar space in the Concord area
and for that reason we were able to
pursue this
questions remember
committee
nine what a pleasure of community
meeting with the excited
the birds are moves to approve executed
by representative
or any discussion on the motion
being none all those favor signify by
saying I I
thank you
moving on
RSA 439 4 colon 39-c disposal of highway
or turnpike-funded real estate the first
item is lrcp
22-020 Department of Transportation
authorization to amend lrcp
21-03434 approved November 9th 2021 to
dispose of two Parcels of state-owned
land located on the Westerly side of New
Hampshire Route 16 Spaulding Turnpike in
the town of Newington by reducing the
acreage size of the two Parcels from
5.20 plus or minus acres to 4.02 plus or
minus acres and decrease the sale price
from one million one hundred eleven
thousand two hundred dollars to
200 which includes a one thousand one
hundred dollar administrative fee for
each parcel so subject to the conditions
that specified in the request dated July
25th 2022
Mr lebronte thank you Mr
at the New Hampshire Department of
Transportation
what we this this parcel
um
this disposal came before the committee
in May and what afterwards what occurred
is it was pointed out that there's a gas
line within the right-of-way of the
Spalding turnpike through discussions
with the the purchaser it was determined
that it was best to reduce the price so
that the gas line would stay within the
public right-of-way and not be on the
private subject not beyond the on the
parcels subject to to an easement and
that's why we're asking to amend this
um
to amend this sale and the reduction of
price they went back and looked at it
and determined that
they adjusted the sale not only for the
reduction in size but also the time the
timing of the sale
thank you uh any questions of the
department for members of the committee
seeing none what is the pleasure of the
committee on item 22-020 representative
Mills moves approval
uh Senator Birdsall uh seconds
the motion is uh approval of item
22-020 is there any discussion on the
motion
seeing none all those in favor of the
motion signify by saying aye
opposed nay the eyes have it and the
motion is approved
next item lrcp
22-021 Department of Transportation
authorization to sell 0.85 plus or minus
of an acre of state-owned land located
at the intersection of Elm Street and
New Hampshire Route 9 in the city of
Keene directly to Paul dubresky the
butter for eleven thousand dollars plus
an Administration administrator fee of
one thousand one hundred dollars subject
to the conditions as specified in the
request dated July 21st 2022 and if I
mispronounce the about his name my
apologies
foreign
thank you Mr chairman
the original parcel was uh 2.12 acres
and was acquired by the department in
1973 via warranty deed for 11 500 to
build the Keen bypass
this parcel was so what we're doing is
we purchased it now this is the remnant
of that logic 2.12 acre parcel so we've
kept over an acre of it to construct the
route nine
route 9. the parcel will conveyed with
the following conditions the department
shall retain a drainage easement to
accommodate the existing 24-inch Culvert
located on on the parcel and the grantee
will be responsible for hiring a land
surveyor and producing a right-of-way
adjustment plan
to be recorded I can take any questions
if
questions for the Department for members
of the committee
see none what is the pleasure of the
committee on item 22-021
Mr chairman
representative Cloutier yes I move we
adopt uh else lrcp 22-021
second that representative Cloutier has
moved that we approve item
22-021 seconded by representative Mills
is there any discussion on the motion
seeing none all those in favor of
commotion signify by saying aye
aye opposed nay the eyes have it and the
motion is approved
next item lrcp
22-022 Department of Transportation uh
request approval to dispose of 0.46 plus
or minus acres of state-owned land with
improvements located at 490 Tasker Hill
Road in the town of Madison by entering
into a listing agreement for the term of
one year with Pinkham real estate for
the sale price of 259 000 allowing
negotiations within the committee's
current policy guidelines and pursuant
to RSA 440
Roman 3-a assess an administrative fee
of one thousand one hundred dollars
subject to the conditions as specified
in the request dated July 28 2022
Department thank you Mr chairman
um this uh 0.46 acre parcel is improved
with a single family residence located
at 490 Taska Hill Road in the town of
Madison uh as you just mentioned we
would like to enter into an agreement
with Tinkham real estate with a five
percent sales commission the sale of
this parcel is we're looking to
add a sales price of 259
000 the department will assess an
administrative fee of eleven hundred
dollars the subject parcel was
originally acquired by the department in
2005 via warranty deed for two hundred
and six thousand we
sent out a
requests for market analysis to all of
our Realtors our pre-approved realtors
in region one we receive six six
responses after reviewing the uh all six
responses the pre-qualification
committee determined that pinkum real
real estate was
the the uh the most familiar with the
area and seem to have the most stable
asking price
just one question has the the building
been vacant since we purchased it no it
hasn't been vacant it has been vacant
for about uh I guess roughly around two
years what happened is it um
it was a habitability problem not
because of the condition of the
structure but because of the well the
well dried up and looking at what we
were getting for it in in rental value
to what we'd have to do to
get the well bat we'd have to drill a
new well it was determined that it
wasn't so that explains he has his uh
yes
okay any other questions
what is the pleasure pleasure of the
committee on item 22-022
chair I move to approve representative
Mills moves approval of
22-022 Senator bird still seconds the
motion is there any discussion on the
motion to approve this item
saying none all those in favor signify
by saying aye
aye opposed nay the eyes have it and the
motion is approved
moving on
lrcp
22-023 Department of Transportation
requests approval to dispose of 2.75
plus or minus acres of state-owned land
with improvements located at 592 Eaton
Road New Hampshire Route 153 in the town
of Conway by entering into a listing
agreement for a term of one year with
Badger Peabody and Smith Realty for the
sale price of two hundred thousand
dollars allowing negotiation within the
committee's current policy guidelines
and pursuant to RSA four colon 40 Roman
3-a assess an administrative fee of one
thousand one hundred dollars subject to
the conditions as specified in the
request dated August 18 2022.
foreign thank you Mr chairman um the
subject parcel was acquired in 2006 for
the Conway bypass for the sale for the
price of two hundred thousand dollars I
will say that I'm not sure if it has
been vacant the entire time but the
structure has been vacant for quite a
while it's actually located next to one
of our
um one of our maintenance sheds
so the department will retain uh 0.75
Acres of the original parcel
um
for the reason for the patrol shed
property the grantee will be responsible
for submitting a subdivision plan
prepared at their expense by a licensed
land surveyor in the state of New
Hampshire uh
market analysis request was sent out to
all of our realtors in region one
four firms responded and it was
determined that Badger was
the most feasible realtor to to market
the property I can take any questions
questions from the committee on this
item
seeing none what is the pleasure of the
committee on item 22-023
uh representative McConkey moves
approval of the item
seconded by representative Mills is
there any discussion on the item
see none all those in favor of approval
of lrcp
22-023 signify by saying I I suppose nay
the ice habit and the motion is approved
foreign
lrcp
22-024 Department of Transportation
requests approval to dispose of 0.15
plus or minus of an acre parcel of State
on land with improvements located at 439
Valley Road in the town of Sullivan by
entering into a listing agreement for a
term of one year with H.G Johnson real
estate for the listing price of 185 000
allowing negotiations within the
committee's current policy guidelines
and pursuant to RSA four colon 40
Romans 3 Dash a assessed an
administrative fee of one thousand one
hundred dollars subject to the
conditions as specified in the request
stated August 29th 2022
thank you Mr chairman uh the subject
parcel was acquired
um and
2017 uh for 150
165 dollars as part of a negotiated
settlement uh the project included
raising the elevation and replacing the
abutting route 9 bridge over
otter Brook as well as roadway
improvements along Route nine
the department will be retaining a
1522 foot Bridge access easement and a
4177 square foot slope and drainagement
the grantee will be responsible for
submitting a subdivision plan uh
prepared at their expense by licensed
land surveyor
all the all the pre-qualified Realtors
in region two were requested to submit
market analysis only two firms responded
and it was determined that H.G Johnson
was the uh the best suited to Market
this property is their local realtor
questions from the committee
um to the department on this item
saying none what is the pleasure of the
committee on item 22-024
representative McConkey moves to approve
seconded by
representative Cloutier
any discussion on the motion
all those in favor signify by saying aye
aye oppose snake the eyes have it and
the motion is approved next item lrcp
22-025 is being withdrawn by the
department
thank you go ahead thank you Mr chairman
yes the department
um is requesting to withdraw this item
at this time uh it was sent over
prematurely
um
what what happened is uh looking at the
property and its development potential
it was determined that by increasing uh
basically we were reserving a truck
turnaround area but it wasn't really
necessary because there's area up
further up the road that trucks can turn
around on and by increasing the area of
uh it would also help with the
development potential of the parcel uh
the problem is this was sent over and I
should have caught it because I signed
off on it so I'm I'm this is on me it
was sent over because we still are in
the figuring it out mode as to what the
increase in area does to
the value of the property
all right what should we table it no
they withdrew it so we're not going to
do anything with it
um and I assume that at some future
meeting
um it'll be back that's correct okay
um thank you that's all from the
Department of Transportation for this
meeting
next item RSA 4 colon 40 disposal of
real estate
lrcp
22-026 department of administrative
Services acting on behalf of the
Department of Environmental Services
requests approval to Grant exclusive
option to Gilson Road solar LLC a New
Hampshire limited liability company to
be formed by solar farm developer Andrew
Keller doing business as New Hampshire
solar garden to lease approximately
25.78 acres of land at the Sylvester
Superfund Site located near Gilson Road
in Nashua New Hampshire consisting
primarily of the cap of of a capped
landfill and the abutting surrounding
state land for a total term of up to 45
years following an option
following an option turn of up to two
years for the purposes of constructing
installing operating and maintaining a
1.1 to 5 megawatt capacity commercial
solar power generation facility
proposed exclusive option fees to obtain
the right to lease the subject properly
property
are one thousand for the first 12 months
and one thousand for for each twenty
thousand each for the two successive
option period extensions of six months
and after uh the option is exercising
construction is complete proposed
annulment of the initial 25-year lease
term is the product of the nameplate
generation capacity of the facility in
megawatts of alternating current and ten
thousand dollars subject to the
conditions that specified in the request
stated August 30
2022 and I'm not sure which department
is going to try to explain this to us
but good luck
uh good morning good morning Mr chairman
I'm Jared Nile and real property asset
manager from administrative Services I
have Michael Summerlin uh of DES in the
super fund management section
um with me uh if you want any of them to
sit with you in case there are questions
that's totally acceptable
Mike so as I understand uh I got
involved uh when Des was looking for
assistance with the actual lease this
this uh
this parcel actually there's two uh tax
Parcels that together
um
uh amount to 20 over 25 acres of a
Superfund Site this is on Gilson Road in
Nashua and
um southwest corner of Nashua uh in a
residential area
um the soup the site is a former gravel
pit and landfill
I don't know the whole history of the
Superfund designation and cleanup but as
I understand it Des got involved to
uh handle the mitigation and supervise
the the mitigation uh in in conjunction
with EPA or as the local representative
of EPA
um
the
active part of the mitigation is now
complete and uh there has been there
have been discussions with uh solar
developer New Hampshire solar garden to
ground lease the site and uh develop it
into a solar commercial solar generation
facility uh I I when I prepared this
request I had understood that the
generation capacity would be one to five
megawatts I'm now told that the
expectation is it will be two megawatts
um
so you know that does affect the rent a
bit if you look at the rent formula it's
the rent over time for the first 25
years it's fixed well it's it's it's a
fixed formula uh ten thousand dollars
times whatever the nameplate generation
capacity is so if it's two megawatts
it's going to be twenty thousand dollars
you know annually for the first 25 years
but after the first 25 years the
extension periods under the lease uh the
amount of rent uh increases first by 25
then by another five percent then by
another five percent over five uh
successive five-year extension terms
um there is a two-year option period at
the beginning of this agreement so the
lease wouldn't actually start until the
developer exercised the option to lease
the property the reason for that is as I
tried to explain in the letter
um the the the lessee is a special
purpose entity that's designed for
transfer to the operator investor in the
site so New Hampshire solar garden is
the developer they they line up all the
pieces and the money and then they get
the owner to come in they find an owner
to come in take over the the lessee
entity and then operate the site
any questions
thank you Warren the first question that
comes to my mind is has anybody talked
to the city of Nashua about this
I'll let Michael answer that excuse me
she could identify yourself good morning
I'm Michael Summerlin with the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services I'm the project manager for the
Sylvester Superfund Site on Gilson Road
in Nashua
in the process of
learning how to lease out state owned
property
we went through the cord
review and as part of that we received
letter of support from Nashua the folks
I've talked to in Nashua are very
supportive
of solar and
okay so thank you because we always are
sensitive to what we're doing to towns
and cities where we
do something with property within their
boundaries
any other Senator Birdsall
um do you know if any of this
electricity is actually going to come to
ensure is it going to go down to the
grid and then get spread out
I don't think that I can answer that
with the exception of my familiarity
with this particular developer
I understand they do primarily net
metering which I think means it goes low
stays local
but I'm not really sure how the solar
aspect works
the advantage of developing a Superfund
Site for solar is that it reduces the
potential for exposure
brought from for human risks uh with com
you know when you compare it to other
types of development
this particular Superfund Site is a cap
surrounded by a fence
about 20 acre cap and
there aren't a lot of ways of
beneficially reusing this site
solar has a win-win because now someone
else will take care of the fence now
someone else will take care of the
mowing instead of the Des
that'll help out a lot
follow-up follow-up and I I get the cap
issue and I'm fine fine with that my
concern is New Hampshire has always been
on the um the bottom of the totem pole
for electricity I want to make sure this
electricity is going to benefit our
constituents and not go down into
um the the grid and then get spread out
amongst Maine New Hampshire and
Connecticut
in Massachusetts
well we can ask and get back to you if
that helps
what's the process for getting back to
you
Dr Senator Birdsall afterward to get her
okay I probably won't yeah
any other questions
go ahead Mark
thank you Mr chairman so how time
sensitive is this lease it would seem to
be an appropriate question by the
Senators is something we can table to
the next meeting how sensitive is this
agreement
time sensitive
well from the des's perspective it's not
time sensitive the developer
has
stated recently that
time is of the essence for
keeping the value of the project
at the level
it's at now to afford the 10 000 per
megawatt AC
lease agreement
a potential lease agreement
so there's been changes lately with
regard to incentives from the federal
government I believe so that probably
has softened that deadline that they had
but that would be another thing I could
learn from the developer and get back to
you on
our next meeting is already scheduled
for two months from now I think that we
could get some of those questions
answered and maybe ask the department of
energy also
to come along and talk about this
because this is a 45-year lease that
deals with
um solar and and our constituents and
electrical um
prices which are high
well geez I missed the question uh there
wasn't a question I was just saying that
if we were to table this item for two
months that I would also expect the
department energy to join you in the in
this because they they should be the
ones to answer
um Senator bird seals questions since
they're now a full agency
and I will be talking to them
any other questions to the Department
table
for you on the table
I think it would be prudent okay I moved
a table
Senator bird Soul moves that we table
item
22-026 until our November meeting second
and representative Mills seconds that
um
all those in any any discussion on the
motion
seeing none
all those in favor of tabling item
22-026 until our next meeting
signify by saying aye
opposed nay
the eyes have it and the table emotion
is approved for the Department please
get the answers in our November meeting
is the last for this current General
Session of the general court and if we
don't get it resolved in November it may
be March or later before before there is
a new long-range committee established
in meeting so please work with
Department of energy and and try to get
the Senators questions answered but
thank you for bringing it up and it is a
a good way to use Superfund Site
if we can work it all out thank you very
much
that was our last action item there are
several informational items from cord
does anybody want to go over those
see no desire to do that in a previous
meeting we had agreed that we would meet
an lob room 201 203 at 9 30 a.m on
Monday November 28 2022 and as I
mentioned that's only a few days before
we become pumpkins in this General
session of the general court ends so
I shall see you all then and with that
uh this meeting
representative Mills moves to adjourn
seconded by Senator birdsil although
it's in favor signify by saying aye
suppose nay the eyes have it and we
stand adjourned until November thank you
all for coming for those who are here
for the capital budget overview
committee which includes several members
who are here
um we meet at 10 15 for one item